AREAS.
>> YOUR REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUE
OVER IN THE SENATE, SENATOR TOM
COTTON, WENT ON --
>> OH, BOY.
>> -- A RADIO SHOW, HE
CRITICIZED THE LAST HEARING BUT
ADMITTED THIS.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> I'LL CONFESS, I WILL CONFESS
I DID NOT WATCH THAT HEARING.
AND I HAVE NOT WATCHED ANY OF
THE HEARINGS.
I'VE NOT SEEN ANY OF THEM OUT OF
THE CONTEXT I SEE A SNIPPET HERE
OR THERE ON THE NEWS.
>> YOUR RESPONSE TO HIM?
>> YEAH, LET ME TELL YOU HOW
HE'S THINKING.
HE THINKS IT IS COOL TO BE IN
FRONT OF THE BASE AND BE, LIKE,
I'M NOT EVEN WATCHING THE
HEARING, GUYS, I'M TOO COOL TO
WATCH THE HEARINGS.
I HAVE MY MIND MADE UP.
THAT PROBABLY WORKS IN THE BASE.
TOM COTTON HAS BUILT A
REPUTATION ON ACTING LIKE THE
TOUGHEST GUY ON THE PLANET, BUT
HE CAN'T EVEN PUT IN FRONT OF
HIS EYES, YOU KNOW, A NARRATIVE
WHICH MAY CHALLENGE HIS SOUL,
THAT HE HAS TO GO TELL HIS
PEOPLE THE TRUTH.
REPUBLICANS THAT ARE WATCHING,
LET ME TELL YOU THIS, EVERY ONE
OF YOUR LEADERS THAT REFUSE TO
TELL YOU THAT THE ELECTION
WASN'T STOLEN, JOE BIDEN IS A
LEGITIMATE PRESIDENT, AND THAT
TRUMP HAS POISONED OUR COUNTRY,
ANYONE THAT REFUSES TO TELL YOU,
THAT DOESN'T BELIEVE IT, 99% OF
THEM, THEY'RE ABUSING YOU,
THEY'RE LYING TO YOU.
AND YOU SHOULD THROW THEM OUT
WITH ANGER BECAUSE YOU NEED
LEADERS THAT TELL YOU THE TRUTH.
BE TICKED AT ME.
BE TICKED AT LIZ CHENEY ALL YOU
WANT.
FINE.
WE CAN TAKE IT.
WE'RE TELLING YOU THE TRUTH.
THE PEOPLE THAT LIE TO YOU AND
PAT YOU ON THE HEAD AND MAKE YOU
FEEL GOOD, BUT THEY'RE ABUSING
YOU, STEALING YOUR MONEY TO STAY
IN POWER.
I HAVE NO SUBPYMPATHY FOR TOM
COTTON OR ANYBODY ELSE LIKE
KEVIN McCARTHY THAT LIES TO THE
BASE VOTER.
>> THOSE BASE VOTERS YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT, THEY'RE NOT
CHANGING THEIR MINDS, LOOKING AT
THE HEARINGS.
IN FACT, OUR DONIE O'SULLIVAN
WENT TO THE DUELLING TRUMP/PENCE
RALLIES IN ARIZONA AND THIS IS
WHAT SOME TOLD HIM ABOUT THE
HEARINGS.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> HAVE YOU BEEN WATCHING THE
JANUARY 6th HEARINGS?
>> I HAVE.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I THINK THEY'RE A BUNCH OF
BULL.
>> WHY?
>> WELL, BECAUSE YOU HAVE BOTH
SIDES.
ARE YOU GETTING ONE SIDE OF THE
STORY?
>> YOU MEAN, LIKE THE SIDE THAT
ATTACKED THE CAPITOL?
>> YOU REALLY BELIEVE THAT
HAPPENED?
>> I WAS THERE.
>> OKAY.
I HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT WERE
THERE TOO.
>> AND?
>> AND SAW THINGS THAT IT WASN'T
WHAT THEY SAY IT WAS.
>> HAVE YOU BEEN WATCHING THE
JANUARY 6th HEARINGS AT ALL?
>> NO.
>> NO, WE SAW IT WHEN IT ALL
WENT DOWN AND SAW A LOT OF THE
BLM AND ANTIFA PEOPLE IN THE
BUILDING AS WELL, AND IT IS
JUST -- IT IS JUST NONSENSE.
>> I THINK LIKE 800 PEOPLE NOW
HAVE BEEN CHARGED, RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
>> AND NONE OF THEM ARE BLACK
LIVES MATTER OR ANTIFA.
>> YEAH, THAT DOESN'T MEAN
ANYTHING.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN ANYTHING.
>> THEY HAVE NOT BEEN BROUGHT
INTO COURT FOR THEIR DUE PROCESS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NOT BEEN
ARRESTED.
>> HUNTER BIDEN HASN'T BEEN
>> I MEAN, YOUR FACE SAYS IT
ALL.
THESE AREN'T OUTLIERS IN THE
TRUMP BASE.
WHAT IS YOUR THOUGHT AS YOU'RE
LISTENING TO THAT?
>> I MEAN, FACTS ARE HARD TO
DIGEST, RIGHT?
THIS IS A VERY ONE-SIDED HEARING
PROCESS.
IT IS VERY ONE-SIDED.
I'LL GIVE THEM THAT.
IT ONLY HAS BEEN REPUBLICANS,
MAINLY REPUBLICANS APPOINTED BY
DONALD TRUMP THAT HAVE
TESTIFIED.
WE HAVEN'T HAD A DEMOCRATIC
WITNESS.
MAYBE ONE OR TWO.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEIR PERSONAL
POLITICAL AFFILIATION.
BUT IT IS ONLY REPUBLICANS
COMING IN AND TESTIFYING.
THEY ARE BEING LIED TO AND
MANIPULATED.
THEY ARE TOLD THAT SOMEHOW NANCY
PELOSI OR MURIEL BOWSER CONTROLS
THE NATIONAL GUARD.
THE ONLY PERSON WITH CONTROL OF
THE D.C. NATIONAL GUARD, BY THE
WAY, IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
THE ONLY PERSON THAT CAN DEPLOY
THE D.C. NATIONAL GUARD.
BUT THEY ARE LIED TO.
THEY ARE -- I MEAN, I COULD GO
ON FOR AN HOUR ABOUT THIS.
I WILL TELL YOU, THOUGH, I
FIRMLY BELIEVE IN FIVE OR TEN
YEARS YOU WILL NOT FIND A SINGLE
PERSON IN THIS COUNTRY THAT WILL
ADMIT TO EVER HAVING SUPPORTED
DONALD TRUMP.
HE'S BECOMING A CANCER.
TRUMP IS A CANCER.
AND THERE WILL BE PEOPLE LIKE
NIXON THAT NEVER ADMIT THEY
SUPPORTED HIM IN FIVE OR TEN
YEARS.
>> I DO WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
SOMETHING WE'RE SEEING WHICH IS
DEMOCRATIC GROUPS WHO ARE
ACTUALLY HELPING PUSH ELECTION
DENIERS IN GOP PRIMARIES, HOPING
FOR AN EASIER MATCHUP IN THE
GENERAL ELECTION.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT AS
SOMEONE WHOSE COMMITTEE IS
EXPOSING THEM?
>> I THINK IT IS DISGUSTING,
BECAUSE, LOOK, YEAH, YOU THINK
YOU MAY HAVE AN EASIER TIME AT
WINNING.
I'LL TELL YOU, AFTER JANUARY,
THERE ARE GOING TO BE A FEW OF
THESE PEOPLE, LOOK AT DOUG
MASTRIANO IN PENNSYLVANIA.
LOOK AT DARREN BAILEY IN
ILLINOIS, AN ELECTION DENIER.
GOVERNOR PRITZKER SPENT TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS SO THAT HE
WOULD WIN.
BY THE WAY, YEAH, PRITZKER HAS A
LITTLE BIT OF AN ADVANTAGE RIGHT
NOW.
GOOD REPUBLICAN YEAR, BAILEY MAY
WIN.
AND YOU SEE THIS IN PETER MEIJER
IN MICHIGAN.
YOU'LL HAVE ELECTION DENIERS
WIN.
WHILE I THINK A CERTAIN NUMBER
OF DEMOCRATS TRULY UNDERSTAND
THE DEMOCRACY IS THREATENED,
DON'T COME TO ME AFTER HAVING
SPENT MONEY SUPPORTING AN
ELECTION DENIER IN A PRIMARY,
AND THEN COME TO ME AND SAY,
WHERE ARE ALL THE GOOD
REPUBLICANS?
YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT DEMOCRACY.
I TRULY BELIEVE ALL THESE ISSUES
WE ARGUE ABOUT, THEY MATTER, BUT
THE THING THAT MATTERS THE MOST
RIGHT NOW IS THE THREAT TO OUR
DEMOCRACY.
IT IS THE THING OUR KIDS WILL
JUDGE US BY.
AND WHEN WE'RE SITTING HERE
PLAYING DCCC, DNC POLITICS,
LET'S PROMOTE THE CRAZY AND THAT
PERSON WINS, YOU DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE REAL THREAT.
I'M SORRY, YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND
THE THREAT TO DEMOCRACY.
>> CONGRESSMAN, WE APPRECIATE
YOU BEING SO GENEROUS WITH YOUR
TIME THIS MORNING.
THANK YOU.
CONGRESSMAN ADAM KINZINGER.
>>> ALL RIGHT, WITH US NOW, CNN
SENIOR POLITICAL CORRESPONDENT
AND ANCHOR OF "INSIDE POLITICS"
SUNDAY ABBY PHILLIP.
LITTLE BIT OF ADAM KINZINGER
UNPLUGGED THERE, TAKING ON THE
DCCC, TAKING ON TOM COTTON,
TAKING ON AT THE VERY BEGINNING,
AND I DON'T WANT TO OVERLOOK
THIS, THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FOR
BRINGING IN MARC SHORT,
BASICALLY SAYING, THANKS, BUT
WHERE HAVE YOU BEEN THE LAST
YEAR AND A HALF.
WOW, ABBY.
>> YEAH, I MEAN, DEFINITELY ADAM
KINZINGER UNPLUGGED.
LOOK, STARTING WITH THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, I ACTUALLY THINK
THIS IS PARTICULARLY
INTERESTING.
THIS COMMITTEE HAS BEEN DRIVING
THE BUS ON THIS INVESTIGATION
AND THEY ARE CLEARLY FRUSTRATED
THAT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
KIND OF PLAYING FOLLOW THE
LEADER HERE AS OPPOSED TO TAKING
ON PARTS OF THIS INVESTIGATION,
MUCH MORE AGGRESSIVELY.
THERE ARE ELEMENTS OF THIS
INVESTIGATION THAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WOULD BE BEST SUITED
TO PURSUE.
WHEN YOU ASKED HIM ABOUT THOSE
TIES BETWEEN TRUMP ALLIES AND
THE EXTREMIST GROUPS, IT IS
CLEAR THE COMMITTEE IS NOT QUITE
THERE YET.
HE DIDN'T QUITE HAVE A FULSOME
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THAT MIGHT
LOOK LIKE, BUT THAT SEEMS TO BE
A CLEAR AREA WHERE THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, WHICH IS ALREADY
PROSECUTING MANUFAE IING MANY O
HAS INVESTIGATIVE TOOLS THAT CAN
LOOK MORE DEEPLY INTO THAT.
YOU SEE THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE BEING A LITTLE BIT
FRUSTRATED.
AND THEN AT THE END THERE, ON
THESE ELECTION DENIERS, THIS IS
A REALLY SERIOUS ISSUE FOR THE
DEMOCRATS, WHERE PEOPLE IN BOTH
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY AND ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE ARE RAISING REAL
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS STRATEGY OF
BOOSTING PEOPLE WHO IN A GOOD
YEAR, AS ADAM KINZINGER SAID,
COULD VERY WELL WIN AND LET'S BE
HONEST, THIS IS A GOOD YEAR FOR
REPUBLICANS.
THIS IS NOT A GOOD YEAR FOR
DEMOCRATS.
SO THEY REALLY ARE PLAYING A
LITTLE BIT OF RUSSIAN ROULETTE
HERE WITH SOME OF THESE
CANDIDATES, DOWN BALLOT, WHO
ARE, YOU KNOW, MANY REPUBLICANS
SAY ARE UNFIT TO HOLD THE
OFFICES THAT THEY'RE RUNNING
FOR.
>> ABBY WHAT DID YOU THINK ABOUT
WHAT HE SAID TO SENATOR TOM
COTTON WHO CRITICIZED THE
HEARINGS, BUT ADMITTED HE DIDN'T
EVEN WATCH ANY OF THE HEARINGS.
KINZINGER BASICALLY SAID
EVERYTHING EXCEPT HE'S A FRAGILE
SNOWFLAKE WHO CAN'T WATCH THE
HEARINGS.
>> YEAH, AND DIRECTED AT THE TOM
COTTONS OF THE WORLD, THE JOSH
HAWLEYS OF THE WORLD, PERHAPS
THE TED CRUZES OF THE WORLD, THE
REPUBLICANS WHO WON'T WATCH THE
HEARINGS, BUT DENOUNCE IT AS A
PARTISAN AFFAIR.
NOW, IT IS PARTISAN IN A CERTAIN
SENSE IN THAT AS CONGRESSMAN
KINZINGER POINTED OUT, MOSTLY OR
PREDOMINANTLY REPUBLICANS HAVE
BEEN TESTIFYING.
BUT IT HAS BEEN NOTABLE.
LOOK, THE FOLKS WHO ARE PUSHING
BACK ON THE HEARINGS SO FAR ARE
NOT DOING SO FROM A PERSPECTIVE
OF THE SUBSTANCE, BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT WATCHING IT, BECAUSE
IF YOU WATCH IT, YOU HAVE TO
CONTEND WITH THE FACTUAL
INFORMATION.
AND ON TOP OF THAT, NOBODY HAS
PUSHED BACK ON THE FACTS THAT
HAVE BEEN PRESENTED ABOUT
TRUMP'S BEHAVIOR OR LACK
THEREOF.
THERE HAS BEEN SOME PUSHBACK
ABOUT PEOPLE'S RECOLLECTIONS,
ABOUT WHAT THE SECRET SERVICE
DID OR DID NOT DO, BUT NOBODY IS
DENYING THAT TRUMP DID NOTHING
ON JANUARY 6th TO STOP THE
RIOTERS VOLUNTARILY.
HE WAS PRESSURED BY HIS AIDES
AND HIS FAMILY TO PUT OUT A
STATEMENT.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO PUT OUT A
STATEMENT AND SO YOU'RE NOT
SEEING REPUBLICANS LIKE TOM
COTTON RESPONDING TO THOSE
FACTS.
AND SO I DO THINK IT IS
JUSTIFIED FOR EVERYBODY TO SAY,
WELL, HOW CAN YOU SAY THAT THE
COMMITTEE IS ILLEGITIMATE WHEN
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT INFORMATION
THEY HAVE BEEN PRESENTING.
>> ABBY PHILLIP, GREAT TO TALK
TO YOU THIS MORNING.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR WATCHING THIS
WITH US.
THE TOM COTTON QUESTION, A
TERRIFIC QUESTION BY YOU,
KINZINGER WAS LOADED FOR BEAR AS
THEY LIKE TO SAY AS SOON AS YOU
MENTIONED TOM COTTON.
>> I THINK HE'S VERY FRUSTRATED
WITH REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
FOR HOW THEY'RE PLAYING POLITICS
WITH THIS.